foreign
[Music]
and welcome to another endgame video we
are starting to move toward the end of
uh the section on Pawn end games time
just seems to fly I can't believe it's
already been something like four videos
in the previous video we talked about
using your king effectively and today we
are going to explore six more advanced
but no less crucial pawn and game
Concepts these are six Concepts that
don't necessarily neatly fit into some
sort of basic category like opposition
or zuzvong they're a little bit more
involved so they're going to take a
little bit more explaining but I'm going
to try to do it as I usually do in an
accessible and understandable way even
if you're not all that experienced in
Pawn end games so don't be afraid of the
word Advanced and as per usual make sure
your desk is clear your phone is off
you've brewed a nice cup of tea or
coffee and well without further Ado
let's delve in and actually before we do
I will point out that this is going to
be the final sort of concept actual pawn
and game video in the next video the
final video on Pawn end games for now
we're going to put everything together
I'm going to give you a set of 10
positions to solve on your own and then
we're going to go through the solutions
uh on the video and uh these 10
positions are going to hit on all of the
concepts that we have covered in uh the
conceptual videos so we're going to do
sort of a large scale review and I will
give you ample opportunities to really
put everything to the test and make sure
that you've mastered all of the crucial
Concepts okay so let's now jump in and
much like the pawn race video rather
than having a definition section and
then a practicum section because these
concepts are a little bit more advanced
they don't necessarily lend themselves
to just kind of a dry definition so I'm
going to give you the definition but I'm
going to do it through the lens of the
actual games we're going to jump
straight into uh the Practical section
and because of that we're going to spend
a little bit longer on each position so
I'm still gonna try to clearly explain
what each concept refers to but we're
going to go straight into the analysis I
just think that'll be a little bit more
practical and uh like in the pawn race
video I'm going to project the
definition over on the top left
hopefully that technology will work and
that way you can consistently refresh
your memory and remind yourselves of
what the overarching theme is for each
example that we look at now in our first
example we're going to review a a
concept that we touched on in the
previous video on using your king we
talked extensively about waiting moves
the waiting move is a pawn move that you
make in order to pass the turn to your
opponent frequently with the aim of
inducing zugspon you might remember is a
situation in which any move that a side
can make harms their position or it
usually leads to a loss or an
undesirable result so there is a sort of
sub-concept within waiting the realm of
waiting moves that I want to hammer home
and I think this example is just great
overall there's tons of cool stuff here
you might recognize the player who has
the white pieces Henry grob that is the
very same grub who developed the opening
named after him one G4 no comment on
that G4 has been in the news a lot
lately Magnus Carlson has played it
icaro both of them have played it I
think to win a title Tuesday but grab is
also a pretty pretty darn strong player
he was a master I think from Sweden and
in this game he faces another very
strong Master Hungarian laiosh Steiner
and we are going to face uh Steiner's
side
so rule number one concept number one is
the waiting move sacrifice uh which is
the process of giving away a pawn in
order to generate an additional waiting
move now you're like well I can read
that too can you remind me uh what
exactly that means and that's exactly
what I'm going to do with this example
now for starters let's begin with some
general observations who's playing for a
win what can we notice in this position
if you watch the previous video
carefully you will know that you should
focus on a couple of things right off
the bat whose King is more active who's
got the capacity to create past pawns
and perhaps most importantly who has how
many waiting moves now neither side has
a past Pawn
for the time being black is the only one
who can create a past Pawn with the move
F5 we'll get to that in a second it does
appear
that Black's King is more active black
skin is on the fifth rank White's King
is on the third Rank and might even
conceivably get pushed away further down
the board so it seems pretty obvious
that black is the one playing for a win
especially because if you count up the
waiting moves white kind of sort of has
one waiting move to move G4 but G4
actually allows Black's King to
infiltrate H4 so it's like a
semi-weighting move black is the only
one with two pure waiting waves there's
A6 and A5 before we start analyzing I
remind you of something very important
from the previous video if you have
waiting moves almost all of the time you
want to be economical with your waiting
moves if you have two of them you don't
want to exhaust both of them at the same
time you want to save as many waiting
moves as possible for a rainy day
because sometimes you have to inducevang
more than once as you try to out
maneuver your opponent's resilient King
so
the first step of course is to consider
the tempting move F5 now from uh the
earlier videos you might remember that
when you have a situation where both
sides have past pawns you want to see
who has the outside pass bomb the pass
Pawn that is furthest away from all of
the other pawns and unfortunately
although black creates a past Pawn here
you're also giving white a passer and
this Jeep on is an outside passer white
is actually completely winning here by
distracting Black's King and then
walking uh his own King over to the
queen side capturing all of our pawns
this is clearly clearly no good White's
gonna play King E4 and you know Black is
Black is busted so we can't break
through directly with F5 that means
we're going to have to adopt a more
subtle method we're going to have to try
to shoulder White's King off of F3 and
somehow infiltrate our way uh to the
king side so as always pause the video
and see if you can figure out a way of
doing that try to calculate as deeply as
you can
foreign
all right so I think the first move is
is pretty pretty straightforward now if
you want to make a waiting move your
default should be to wait with your King
right if you can avoid spending a pawn
waiting move then you should and I think
a lot of people would think oh let's
play A6 it's the right concept but here
you're exhausting a waiting move you can
do exactly the same thing but by moving
your king over to the side King H5 is
the only correct first move
and the reason this works is because
well white still has to move his King
back the move G4 allows King H4 and here
white is immediately in zuzuang and
loses the game so grob plays King back
to F2 and this is a very sensible move
now black advances to G4 so we've made
some progress but white steps into the
opposition and black can make no further
progress with his King but this is where
the waiting moves come in so handy and
Steiner a student of the end game he
watched our videos not just kidding this
game was played I think in the 1950s but
he knows about being economical with his
waiting moves and so he correctly plays
a six rather than A5 this forces whites
King off of G2 now which way is grob
going to go well if he goes to H2 then
black wins on the spot with King F3
that's obvious white plays the move King
F2 and here it looks like uh We've
succeeded the black king now infiltrates
to H3 but it's not just enough to say oh
well now I have infiltrated you actually
have to make progress with your king and
in the previous videos we've seen some
examples where yeah you infiltrate but
then you hit some sort of a dead end and
once again uh it may appear that white
steps into opposition with King F3 and
black cannot make any progress the Kings
just keep dancing around between H1 H2
and H3 but no no no this is where the
second waiting move comes in handy with
the white King on F2 the best move is
now A5 putting white in a second zugsbon
now remember if white pushes the pawn
you'll revert back to the initial idea
you just bring your king back to H4 and
we've already seen this zuke's vong
before white loses the pawn
but if white plays King F3 which is the
only other move then you shoulder the
king from behind we play the move King
to G1 and you continue to push White's
King out of the king side again if white
plays G4 you just come back to actually
no here you don't come back to H2 I
apologize here
um and and we will see almost an
identical scenario unfold in uh the game
so let's uh pause this line for now
because the way grub played leads to
essentially exactly the same uh position
so after King G1 in fact G4 is is really
the only feasible move here because if
white does anything else if white plays
King E3 then black wins Elementary with
King G2 and and King G3 if white plays
King G4 then this is also very easy we
step into the opposition King F5 we take
the Pawn King takes F6 and hopefully you
were able to calculate up to this point
where black wins The Pawn on e4 and then
promotes uh the epon but Henry Grubb he
calculates all this and he says I don't
want to cooperate I don't want to let my
opponent put me in so he decides to play
the move A5 he sacrifices a pawn in
order to deprive black of his second
waiting move and after B takes A5 King
F3 is it now time to panic we don't have
any more waiting moves we can't make any
progress with our King that's it the
game is drawn well no it's not and
that's where our first Advanced concept
comes in handy we have seen that already
in the previous video if your opponent
does something like this if you have
doubled pawns you can usually give the
front Pawn away in order to regenerate
that waiting move which you need so
desperately so Mr Steiner he plays King
H2 King F2 although you could play this
uh what he's about to do immediately
with the King on H3 doesn't matter he
gives away the pawn with A4 white has to
take it and now here comes the second
waiting move A5 this is a ubiquitous
method you're always almost always going
to have this if your opponent plays a
move like A5 and now white is once again
in zugsvang Rob plays King F3 Steiner
plays King G1 and here as we were
discussing grab plays the most resilient
move he plays G4 this is a super
resilient resource and actually not only
does black have only one winning move
black has to find this move in order not
to lose so once again pause the video
make sure that you figure out where
Black's King should go and try to
calculate until the end end of the line
figure out what grab is up to with this
move G4
so the tempting move and the move that I
almost recommended by my mistake is King
back to H2
and you might say well King F2 King H3
King F3 King H4 we've seen this a
million times by now white is in zugspot
but clearing the pathway G5 and white
wins the game this is grab's idea and
hopefully you're able to spot this F
takes G5 King G4 now black skin is the
one that gets shouldered and white skin
reaches the E Pawn First and wins in
exactly the same way that we just saw
black winning
so crab was just a devilish idea and so
black has to maneuver a lot more
astutely the correct move here is King
F1 continuing the shoulder shouldering
process
grub of course
has to play G5 if he steps away with his
King he you know the shouldering gets
complete King G3 King E2 or King E3 King
G2 is is easy and after G5 FG King G4
Steiner was able to calculate this out
correctly until the final Zug Swanky
plays King E2
why white has to take on G5 if you say
well I learned in the pawn race video
that you shouldn't take any unnecessary
pawns let's start racing after King F5
uh the simplest the simplest win is just
King F3 G4 and uh oh actually here you
can just take the pawn and here black
wins the pawn race uh by a Tempo so that
doesn't work white has to play King
takes G5 and now black plays King D3
King F5 and King D4 this is a very
famous Loop song you see this particular
type of a lot of different end games you
know these other pawns are just window
dressing what you should really be
focused on are the e-pawns and the way
that the kings are positioned I think
there might even be a name for this uh
but I don't remember the point is white
is in zug's one the king can't keep in
contact with the E4 pawn and Henry Grubb
this is move 109 a heroic effort by
Steiner he resigned in this position
because once he moves to skin away black
captures on e4 steps away and promotes
the e-pawn so the crazy thing is that
this is like tempo for Tempo once you
started the shouldering process black
was at risk of losing the game if he had
miscalculated and so apart from our
first concept uh the really the Gloom of
what made everything tick was this A4 A5
sacrifice without which black would have
been able to make no progress at all but
in addition you can just see the
importance of calculating these types of
end games out until the very end until
the final Zoo there's three separate
zugsvongs that you have to put white in
in order to make progress the first one
comes here you make it to the fourth
rank then another Zoo number two you
make it to the third rank actually no
four Zuzu song the third one is here
finally you get to the first Rank and
then the final one occurs in the final
position after King D4 but the key
takeaway when you have doubled pawns you
can give one of them away in order to
regenerate that extra waiting move on we
go to concept number two and here I'm
going to make an exception to my sort of
general rule about not showing famous
games the game that I'm about to show is
in fact Super Famous but I think it's
famous for a very good reason we have to
pay tribute to Akiba Rubenstein you know
search them on Wikipedia read about him
one of the strongest players of the 20th
century I love Rubenstein he really
developed a lot of the positional
Concepts that we take for granted now
you know his positional understanding
for the early 1900s was off the charts
he never became world champion but he
beat you know all of the top players of
the day alakon capablanca Etc many many
times however his weakness though was
tactics if he was a little bit better at
tactics I think he would be world
champion super talented player and this
end game is one of his best
so concept number two let me you know
perform this very high tech uh maneuver
here with my word document I'm gonna
close number one and at the end I'm
going to display all of them so don't
really worry about uh taking all of it
down uh immediately I call this mowing
the lawn and I refer uh to mowing the
lawn as a trade of Pawns that uh
obstructs the pathway to a weak Pawn or
set of Pawns which are often located on
the other side of the board you're like
holy smokes is like this reminds me of
my days in college when I read a
philosophy paper what does this say let
me read that again mowing the Lawns
involves trading a pawn or a set of
Pawns that are obstructing a path that
your king can take to a certain set of
other pawns that you wish to attack and
this I think you can see why is the
reason why I am trying to illustrate
these examples directly illustrate these
Concepts directly with an example
because so many of them are just much
easier to understand if you actually see
this thing in action now Mark zoretsky
in his endgame manual refers to this
technique as widening the beach head I
did not know what a beachhead was I had
to look it up a beachhead apparently is
a military line that's set up on a beach
and you know then you can kind of
understand uh what it what it means to
widen it but I like to invent fun names
for things so hopefully you'll
appreciate uh the the analogy here with
mowing the lawn so what the heck does
this mean you're like I want to see this
in action you know mowing the lawn up
what is that so let's look in this
position yes this is not a pawn end game
just yet but Eric Cohn rubenstein's
opponent plays a very instructive
mistake he plays the move Rook C1
offering a rook trade that black cannot
refuse if you refuse this trade then
white infiltrates the seventh rank so
Rubenstein says well I'm going to take
on C1 and the first thing Akiba
Rubenstein does is apply one of the
rules from our previous video on using
your king he charts a a course and this
is a perfect illustration of charting of
course because it isn't immediately
clear where Black's King should go do
you go toward the center do you go to
the king side how do you not not get
overwhelmed in this situation well I
mentioned in the last video that when
you're charting a course you should
start by trying to figure out what your
opponent's most accessible and most
significant Pawn weakness is does your
opponent have any maybe isolated pawns
that can be attacked with your King well
if I put it that way you should
immediately see that there in fact is an
isolated Pawn on H2 and Black's King has
a direct Pathway to that pawn you can
play King F6 uh and then oh and I think
I might not have had uh the move sounds
enabled but let me enable them now
uh hopefully not not too big of a deal
but you have a direct Pathway to that
pawn on on H2 it just only takes you a
couple of moves to get there you might
also notice that if you try to uh get to
the queen side via the center White's
not just going to uh sit around uh oh no
not I he's just gonna bring his King up
to D3 and we are at a dead end white has
plenty of squares that he can just
toggle uh between with his King so
there's no chance of inducing zuke's
bong here and so oncuber ruinstein
Begins by advancing his King charting a
course and walking his King over to H3
now Cohen saw this of course he saw this
and he is able to get his own gang just
in time tempo for Tempo to G1 and this I
think is where uh rubenstein's opponent
stopped calculating he figured that he's
just going to move his King between H1
and G1 for all of infinity and how on
Earth is black going to make progress
the moment Black's King steps back from
H4 well whites King follows him in turn
and you're only white is the one making
progress here what on Earth does black
do in order to try to win this game this
is where we see the concept of mowing
the lawn or widening the beachhead in
action and I think this is the finest
illustration of this concept that I have
seen pause the video take a sip of a
coffee figure out what Black's plan is
and my recommendation here is to focus
Less on the individual moves and more on
your target position what it is that you
want to achieve at in the end
so in order to understand rubenstein's
Mo here
uh let's break this down conceptually
what do we see well we see pawns on
either side of the board there's
kingside pawns and there are queen side
pawns now of course we also see the
blacks King is you know incomparably
more active than its vis-a-vis so
imagine a scenario where all of the
pawns just magically disappeared from
the King side all of them disappeared
from the King side what would happen in
that situation for a black to move well
just imagine that in your head right no
pawns on the king side well black would
probably walk the king over to the queen
side right King G3 and then King F3 and
then King E3
Etc et cetera and whites king would only
be able to follow on the first rank up
until the black king reaches B3 actually
hey I just opened chess base I am just
going to I wasn't planning this but I'm
going to set this up to help people
visualize this because I think it is a
very important concept and there's going
to be a a really cool trick a really
cool caveat here so you might notice
that what I I'm about to say right now
isn't strictly correct uh in one
particular regard but you know stay stay
tuned so
all of the pawns are gone from the uh
from from the King side and then we
would get the following position
analysis board let's paste it in we
would get the oh of course it's uh chess
bases throwing an error let's see all
right there we go
oh no it's not
you know this this is working every
every time up until I actually I
actually need it to work
um
yeah I don't know why it's not uh not
letting me uh let me try it let me try
um
saving this as a PGN and if that doesn't
work then we'll just have to do the
visualization in your head or you could
set it up on a board there we go now it
works so
it's black to play right well if it's
black to play the win is very Elementary
just here and then here and then here
and then here and then you just get to
B3 and then you just win both of uh
White's pawns hopefully that helps you
visualize the Target now we go back to
the position on the board and let's flip
the board
of course that might be the target
position but there are a gazillion pawns
on the king side and this is where we
can mow the lawn we can use our own
pawns to trade off as many of White's
pawns as possible in order to open up
the pathway to the other side of the
board where are contained White's weak
pawns now as it turns out in practice
the plan has a little bit of a
modification what Rubenstein actually
does is he trades three of White's pawns
and leaves one of those pawns intact and
the pawn that he leaves intact is
actually the pawn that he will end up
winning so let's watch how he does that
he starts with the move E5
and that is not the only move you could
really start with a bunch of different
moves but this is as good as any and the
reason I like this move is because it
immobilizes it deep freezes in a way
White's entire Pawn majority
white cannot play F4 because you just
take it and drop your king back so this
is a clinical way to start and I like
rubenstein's next move too he now plays
B5 because this isn't gonna hurt right
deep freezing White's Queen side pawns
definitely isn't going to hurt you're
also depriving white of a waiting move
who knows maybe that'll come in handy
later as it turns out it actually does
so B5 one of those moves that you can
really play without calculating too much
you can kind of bet that this move is
going to turn out well for you
Cohen has nothing he can do other than
to move his King back and forth and now
Rubenstein continues to advance his
spawns he plays F5 and after King H1 he
very patiently brings yet another Pawn
up to G5 now you might say why isn't he
mowing the lawn let's go E4 well you
don't need to rush with this move right
this move isn't going anywhere because
if white plays E4 then White's just
doing Black's work for him black
actually wants to trade this Pawn as
you'll see so there's no rush Rubenstein
brings all four of his pawns up to the
fifth ranking H1 and only now this he
began the actual process of mowing the
lawn he plays the move G4 the move E4
was equally possible I mean these moves
basically transpose into each other uh
we will get this exact position in the
game so there's multiple ways of
achieving this he plays G4 the mowing
process begins with the trait of the F3
Pawn now erricone played the the
response E4 we'll get to that in a
moment what would happen if white
obliged to White traded on G before well
there's there's multiple winning methods
here but the most consistent one the one
that that is uh most clearly illustrates
uh the concept of one is f takes G4
white again has nothing he can do other
than King G1 now it is worthwhile to
advance our Pawn to E4 once again deep
freezing the F2 pawn and now the mowing
process continues H4 King G1 and The
crucial move G3 this now forces white to
trade all of the pawns HD3 hg3 and after
fg3 King G3 the mowing process is
complete and here you can see what I was
saying right technically we the pawn
that we're actually trying to win now is
the E3 pawn and there's actually a very
interesting reason for that as you will
see if the pawn on E3 and the pawn E4
were gone
it would actually not be winning for uh
for black which sounds pretty crazy
but um
we'll get to that we'll get to that
shortly so uh let's take a rain check on
that one of course as you can see black
just wins E3 and wins the game if white
tries to play E4
this will lead to uh essentially the
position from from the game
so hopefully the concept is becoming a
little bit clearer in the game after G4
cone responds with E4 uh prosaic trap
obviously do not take on F3 and allow
white to promote the pawn Rubenstein
instead trades on e4 and continues the
mowing process H4 and G3 and the
important thing here is that
afy tries to play H takes G3 H takes G3
cone resigned in this position if white
plays F3 and says I'm not letting you
get to the king side well black just
goes G2 this is where depriving white of
the waiting move really comes in handy
because now white is in zugsvong King F2
King H2 wins for black and if white
tries to break through hey I'm promoting
my Pawn hopefully you can see that this
is a paper Tiger King G3 and this is a
classic idea that you should be familiar
with mate with two pawns and a king if
you really want to troll your opponent
play the move A6 here but uh not
recommended I didn't tell you that so
there's just nothing that white can do
if white plays King F1 then there are
two ways to win you can take on G2 on F2
and shoulder the um the white king but
the clinical method is G2 checking G1
and this is where saving that waiting
move again and again you can see that
concept coming in handy A6 induces
zougsvong F3 King steps into G3 is this
stalemate no it's not because white
still has pawn moves we talked about
this in the previous video A4 B takes A4
and after B5 A3 black promotes first and
black remotes uh with a queen and with
with Checkmate more trolling you can
actually make a bishop in this position
you can actually make a bishop of this
position and then Checkmate on D4 but
again I wouldn't recommend these things
because once in a blue moon they will
backfire
um so you know go ahead and make a queen
and deliver Checkmate a cone resigned
after H takes two three because if he
takes on G3 then much like with the
pawns shifted one square forward does it
matter because black picks up the pawn
in E4 and then uses E5 Pawn as a decoy
and takes care of the remaining Queen
Side Pawn so that's really all that
mowing the lawn is it's engineering a
series of Pawn trades in order to clear
pathway for your king to access a
weakness or a set of weaknesses it's
it's hopefully pretty straightforward
now
um You might remember that I mentioned
something weird about it being a draw if
uh you know if there weren't a set of
e-pawns like what is all that about
again hold the thought because for me to
illustrate that we need to talk about
our third concept and our third concept
is what I refer to as moving your
opponent's pawns let's do the procedure
again
all right cool so moving your opponent's
pawns uh refers to one or multiple Pawn
sacrifices that are aimed at shifting
your opponent's Pawns in a favorable
Direction now sacrifices in Pawn end
Games should be nothing new to right the
most common type of sacrifice is of
course the Breakthrough and we've talked
about breakthroughs in a separate video
but that's not the only reason why you
would sacrifice a pawn there's a more
advanced reason and that is uh what I
refer to as moving your opponents Pawns
in uh the direction that is favorable to
you now what is a favorable Direction
entail what does that mean well again
the easiest way to illustrate this is
with a a position and this actually I
forgot to label this but this is a study
this is a composed position by uh Herman
Madison who was a not like the president
I think it's m-a-t-t-i-s-o-n
um he was a Latvian master and a very
prolific study but he composed some
brilliant positions and this is one of
them love this position as an
illustration of this concept it is white
to play and draw the game white is
trying to draw pause the video and see
what you can come up with here and note
that is not a slip of the tongue even
though you can take the pawn on G5 your
first step is to figure out why it is
white rather than black who's trying to
make a draw here
all right so hopefully you were able to
figure out that white is inevitably
going to lose both of his pawns
whichever way you capture on G5 black is
either going to play King H5 and take
both pawns like that or black is going
to play King H5 King G4 and eliminate
the pawns on F4 and G5 so you know we're
screwed either way right
now how do we even go about starting to
think here well it's hard to solve this
problem unless you're familiar with the
rudiments of King and pawn versus King
end games we're not going to delve into
that right now the bottom line is that
if you're on the defending side if
you're the side with the King you want
your opponent's Pawn to be as far along
as possible the worst case scenario is
one in which uh the enemy King is very
very far into your territory and the
pawn is very far behind because that
gives your opponent waiting moves and it
gives him the possibility to unroll the
red carpet so the correct first move
is actually H takes G5 F takes G5 loses
after King H5 and there's just nothing
you can do with your pawns black will
eliminate both of them and this is
indeed a worst case scenario you can say
oh I get the opposition it's a draw it's
not a draw black has that waiting move
F6 and hopefully you know the procedure
King E3 King G4
there will later be a separate video on
theoretical end games so if you're
pretty hazy about this don't worry don't
feel bad you can set this up and figure
this out with an engine uh for now but
you can take my word for it this is
winning for black uh in in through
relatively conventional means so what we
would like is a situation like this
except for with black spawn somehow
already on F5 but Black's not going to
push the plot to fi we have to make him
do it and this is where the concept
comes in handy so after HD xg5 check
black will play King H5 and here the
critical moment occurs
but notice that white has a rather
interesting idea we could for example
make a king move King G2 and after King
G4 we could move our opponent's Pawn by
playing G6 right there's a lot of
breakthrough we're just sacking our Pawn
to get black spawn closer as close as
possible uh to the front line
unfortunately black spawn is now not
close enough you could try another
sacrifice you could play F5 but as it
stands as it happens after G takes F5 ah
darn the kings are already in opposition
white is the one with uh in Zug song but
we're actually getting somewhere if it
was black to move here then we actually
have succeeded if it was black to move
here it would be a draw the pawn is
close enough to the enemy King so can we
modify this idea in order to make it
black to move in that position well as
it turns out the only way to do that is
to immediately start with the move G6
it's a brilliant idea if the king takes
then well this is easy we can just
defend the pawn with our King we will
lose the pawn black black will play F6
here and shoulder our king or actually
no we won't we don't even have to lose
the punny play King E3 King G4 King E4
and if black plays F5 you'll notice uh
the similarity with that previous grab
example white actually wins here so
black has to give up the pawn
so that's that's not uh not interesting
and so of course black will play F takes
G6 and here is the critical moment if
you allow King G4 you lose you have to
sacrifice the second Pawn immediately we
play F5 using the concept A second time
moving black spawn onto the same file as
the king and now we are able to make a
draw not by moving the king up to G2 or
H2 these are mind squares and uh we will
develop a more formal term for them very
shortly if you play either of these
moves you allow black to step into
opposition instead you wait around with
King G1 and now black cannot cross the
fourth rank because if he does you are
the one who steps into opposition with a
draw King G4 King G2 King H4 King H2 or
King G5 we keep chilling we play King F1
King F4 King F2 if black plays King H4
again we play King F2 notice diagonal
opposition and it is here as it usually
is a means to an end King G4 King G2
whichever way you slice it white is the
one who steps into opposition and
there's just nothing that black can do
you hold the first rank until black
crosses the fourth rank with his king or
with his Pawn after which the pawn is in
front of the king and then it's really
easy uh at this point it really doesn't
even matter who has opposition
and this constitutes the notion of
moving your opponent's pawns sacrificing
your own pawns to shift your opponent's
pawns favorably now you might say well
this is a composition can you show me a
real life example of somebody doing this
I absolutely can't and this is where we
are going to move to should have
rewinded that but that's okay this is
we're going to combine two of the
previous Concepts together mowing the
lawn and moving your opponent's pawns
there's a backstory behind this game
that's really cool this is a game
between two strong Grand Masters SLR
person and Marcus ragger who's close to
2700 this was played in 2015 in a
tournament in Denmark I was playing at
that tournament I remember this game
happening it was a pretty non-descript
game it wasn't like a super fun game or
anything I finished my game pretty early
and then I went back to my hotel and
then I was looking through the games
from from the round and I looked through
this game and something really really
weird happened at the end of this game
well what happened at the end of this
game well to unlock that let's figure
out how Marcus ragger attempted to win
this position with the black pieces and
it goes without saying that black is
playing for a win just because of
Black's immense uh advantage in King
activity now you might notice the
similarity between the Rubenstein game
in this game once again we have a set of
Pawns on the on the queen side that
black would love to have a turnout with
his King unfortunately there are pawns
that are obstructing the pathway of the
king and if you play King F4 uh then
white will move up to F2 actually I
apologize it is white to move here and
and white played played the move before
deep freezing deep freezing black spawns
and depriving black of waiting moves on
the queen side so uh so now the the fact
remains King F4 white plays King F2 and
you just aren't able to make it to the
queen side in time King E3 uh King E5
King E3 but here is where uh mowing the
lawn comes in handy black can actually
get rid of these pawns but you have to
do it in a very specific way you can't
just get rid of them uh nonchalantly you
have to do it while maintaining the
superiority of your king placement right
if your king ends up in Timbuk2 by the
end of the mowing lot operation then
you're not going to be able to access
the queen side pawns uh at all so ragger
starts by playing F5 white has no choice
but to wait around with King G1 now
black initiates the process G4 forcing
the the trade F takes G4 now an
important moment after hd4 would be
wrong because you are no longer going to
be able to trade the last pair of bonds
why Place King F1 and whichever way
black goes white claims opposition King
H2 King F2
and here actually white wins
after King G3
because you can assure this you can
confirm this yourself but white gets to
Black spawns first so this would
backfire
remember from the previous video
shouldering isn't always good right
shouldering is something that has to be
undertaken very carefully you have to
make sure that you actually are going to
benefit from it by being closer to the
other set of Pawns
if Black Goes King F4 well then white
plays actually not King F2 very
instructive moment here black plays G3
and gets the opposition no white plays
King E2 using the fact that white has
this waiting move if Black Goes King E4
white executes the move and we have a
dead draw with the kings dancing around
just notice all of these nuances and
subtleties this is why you have to take
your time in Pawn end games and like I
said opposition it's not a cure all you
shouldn't get opposition every chance
you can you have to actually
contextualize uh you have to make
specific observations about the position
at hand Pawn end games are devilish so
instead ragger takes back with the King
now the pawns are on adjacent files
which means that they can be traded
white steps in to F2 and this is where
the sort of main part of Black's idea
comes in you play the move F4 this is a
waiting move but it it also happens to
be part of the plan right you're
advancing the pawn to F3 you're forcing
white skang back where are you forcing
it back to either the first drink or the
second rank it doesn't matter because
we're going to get the same position and
here something crazy happened the
notation ended I was like there's no way
the game ends here later I figured out
the game did end here hill art person
resigned he put his King down in this
position he and rag are both assumed
that the mowing lawn operation was a
success and that there was nothing white
could do what made them make this
assumption well it was the following
variation whichever way white goes black
will go King G3 for example let's say
King E2 King G3 King F1 and we complete
the mowing the lawn operation with F3
much like Rubenstein did trading the
last pair of Pawns and black will simply
make his way to the queen side and
eliminate both of White's pawns what
could be more prosaic than that
now you might say I get it what they
missed was the move King Juan and you
can't take the pawn because of stalemate
you would be wrong because after F takes
you do it is not stalemate you still
have a pawn move and black plays B takes
A4 and promotes we've seen this before
the actual reason involves using the
third concept after gf3 King F3 white
has a way to make a draw and hopefully
at this point you're already itching to
play this move you can move your
opponent's pawns but you can't do it
immediately if you do it immediately
then you will allow black to promote his
a pawn so first you have to inch your
King close King you won King E3 already
you can play A4 but if you want to be
safe you can play King D1 King D3 and
you can actually procrastinate one more
move
um you can play kc1 but after King C3
you already have to move your opponent's
bonds this is the move both players
especially Hillar person missed white
plays A4 sacking the pawn but if black
takes you know the drill you've got
Corner pawns Corner pawns never win no
matter how many of them they're are this
is a dead drop if black plays King takes
before then we get a similar scenario
from uh to the Madison study where white
plays ab5 ab5 and white steps into
opposition with King B2 so this is one
of those famous examples of premature
resignation if I did that I don't know
how I would sleep for the next three
weeks
now black is no way to avoid the
scenario none because you know if we
fast forward here A4 let's say King C3
um takes takes you can see one this is
different than you know let's say white
plays A4 earlier black can dance around
right but again as long as you avoid
playing King B2 here which hopefully
you're not inclined to play you can play
King B1 you can play King so you can do
whatever you want to do as long as you
meet King takes before with the move
King uh B2 and this is how black mode
the lawn decree winning chances but
white could have moved his opponent's
pawns at the right moment in order to
salvage the draw and this is why I keep
a Rubenstein needed to keep exactly one
pair of Pawns on the center uh because
of this scenario
okay so on we go to the fourth concept
and I think this video will also
probably be over an hour but that's okay
I I really really want to get through
all six of these
hopefully you're enjoying
um the video so far and hopefully these
Concepts aren't too uh you know too
complicated I think you know the example
should should be doable
um and our fourth concept is uh inducing
weaknesses uh in inducing a weakness
refers to a type of Pawn breakthrough or
trade with the aim of creating a more
accessible weakness or breaking down a
pawn chain we kind of broached this
topic in the Breakthrough video but I
want to give it a little bit more
coverage because it's super important
and it is the source of a large number
of terrible blunders this game is a
perfect illustration of that two strong
players I think this game was played in
the Czech Republic a couple decades ago
and uh it's black to play in this
position now it looks like a dead draw
just it's a totally locked up position
neither King has really any entry points
uh White doesn't have any entry points
because that D6 Pawn is covering uh E5
and C5 and you can't get rid of it h4h5
that's totally futile black doesn't have
to respond to that either I assume that
both players probably were kind of
already looking at each other and
thinking about where they're going to go
for dinner
um and black decided to kind of
accelerate the process a little bit and
play the move A5 and bettox logic was
that he was just going to push the pawn
to average to make sure that he locks up
the queen side entirely and that's it we
can chill with the King literally
nothing white can do but a keen and game
player will notice something very
interesting the move A5 breaks down
Black's own punch and now the pawn on B5
is undefended and you have to pay
attention to every undefended Pawn on
the board in a pawn end game because
that pawn is a weak link and all of a
sudden after White's next move black I
assume came close to falling out of his
shirt how did stulik punish his opponent
for his in cautious previous move
well this one is pretty straightforward
folks the move of course is a four this
is a sacrifice in name only it is
because the pawn is undefended that this
move Works had black just played a
neutral move A4 is still a good try but
black doesn't have to react to it black
can just keep moving back and forth with
his King now after A5 A4 black does have
to react because the pawn on B5 is
hanging and if black takes on A4 then
the pawn on C4 becomes a gaping massive
weakness white captures it steps back
with his King and creates a past Pawn in
the center while black uh has nothing
that he can do with these uh crippled
doubled Pawns in the corner so instead
betock tried King D7 but all the same
white plays King E3 there's no rush to
take the pawn you could take it but you
can delay King C7 he brings his King up
to D4 King B6
trade on B5 and here comes the second
important moment black still has some
hope black is clinging on to dear life
but hopefully you also evaluated The
Waiting move situation and you saw that
white has two waiting moves and you need
to use again and again and again you
actually need to use both of them to
avoid losing if you were to play H4
black would use up his one waiting move
and put white and zugswang you would
have to step back with your king and
allow Black's King to win the D5 Pawn
black wins the game again as you can see
the margin of error in these Pawn end
games is so low very often like the
difference isn't between oh you win the
game if you make the right move and if
you don't then then the game ends in a
draw very often like you actually lose
if you don't follow the rules to the
letter you play H3 black plays A4 and
now white plays H4 forcing black skin
off of B5 black loses the C4 pawn and
white won the game after King D3
King B5 and now
um I'm not sure actually I think there's
a mistake in the in the notation says
King D2 but key D2 is a horrendous move
my guess is that white actually played
King D4 and uh black stepped away to A5
white played C4 King B4 and now
hopefully you are itching to play this
move C5 the classic Pawn breakthrough
dc5 now where should White's King go
this is still an important moment you
don't actually want to go back to D3 if
you do that you allow black to push C4
and carve out a pathway to C5 or
breakthrough with C3 instead you want to
move the king as far away from the pawn
checks as possible you go King E5 and
this Pawn race is easy to calculate King
B3 D6 and takes B2 D7 A3 d8 Queen and
white wins uh easily or if black tries
C4 D6 C3 here bc3 is check that's
important otherwise black would play A3
and the pawns would promote
simultaneously here white promotes first
D7 and white wins but all of the trouble
started when black made this unnecessary
Pawn push allowing white to induce the
weakness break down the remaining Pawn
chain and move his King into the
critical Square now I want to show you
another example of this concept because
of how crucial it is and we're going to
go pretty quickly through this one all
right let's flip it on this is one of my
favorite illustrations it's from one of
my games and again I forgot to label
this this is my one of my games from the
world youth Chess Championship under 12
which I did win this was back in 2007
but my coach was really angry at me over
this particular game now in this game
and I think this was round three it's
white to move I'm playing white and
clearly white has a big Advantage we've
got this monster night sitting on D4 but
the big question that white has to
answer here is whether we want to
transition into a pawn and get my
opponent with his last move offered a
trade of all minor pieces you know the
drill pause the video figure out whether
or not white should go into the pawn end
game
foreign
so the answer indeed is yes you should
go into the pawn end game and I answered
the question incorrectly
so
at first glance the end game might seem
completely winning you might say well I
noticed that I have a past spot it's an
outside passer so well I'm just going to
use that pawn as a decoy and I'm going
to race my king over and eliminate all
of Black's pawns I'm going to chart a
course to the H7 Pawn but if you
actually calculate the line you you will
realize that even the whites King starts
the race first Black's got a Ferrari in
reality White's weaknesses are just
mathematically closer uh than than the
H7 Pawn so here's what happens King D4
King takes before and hopefully you were
able to calculate this King takes D5
King C3 King E6 King D it's actually not
even close black was already taking all
of White's Pawns being H7 King G3 and
black wins the game King takes G6 F4 and
uh black remotes first and uh wins wins
the end game so this is not an option
another example of the natural
continuation failing
now what did I miss right I calculated
this line and assumed that the pawn
ending is not worth going into
what I forgot about is that King takes
D5 is actually well we can play King
takes D5 or we can play the critical
move in this position it actually really
doesn't matter but for the sake of
illustration uh we're gonna play it here
now in this situation you should notice
that Black's King is currently
shouldered by whites against an
opposition so you don't technically have
to rush with King takes D5 so you might
say ah well what if we don't take
unnecessary pawns what if we go straight
for the H7 Pawn this also isn't going to
work Black's going to take the pawn on
F2 and then break through with precisely
the pawn that you didn't end up
capturing also not an option what you
need to use to employ is the fourth
concept you need to modify the pawn
structure on the king side such that
Black's Pawn weaknesses are going to be
more accessible to whites King you need
to create a new weakness and the way
that you do that is with a brilliant
move G4 you strike at Black's Pawn chain
forcing black into an unresolvable
dilemma if black takes on G4 then white
eliminates both of these Pawns in one
Fell Swoop and gets a protected passer
on E3 this wins the game on the spot for
example King the two King F4 King E2 and
the simplest is just eliminate the pawn
on G4 and push your Pawn to promotion
this is nothing to calculate here of
course black is going to ignore White's
G form and black is going to play King
B3 to prepare to uh circumvent white
skin but this is where the strategy
Works to Perfection after the trade on
F5 hopefully you can see that there is a
new weakness which is so much more
accessible to white skin F5 is now
undefended and you easily win the king
race you go King E5 you start eating
first and you start eating last after
King takes E4 white has won all of black
spawns King drops into F4 Paving the way
for the E Pawn to promote so what I
missed is This brilliant move G4 I
assumed that you have to take on D5 you
can take on D5 and then play G4 this is
just a transposition
um but I think G4 is even more pure even
more pretty so remember you don't just
have to accept the pawn structure as it
is you can use your pawns sometimes even
a sacrifice in order to shatter certain
Connections in your opponent's Pawn
structure and make more weaknesses that
you can then attack
okay we've got two more Concepts to get
through let's try to do it in about 15
minutes
the first of these is a another notion
that we have touched on in the previous
video and it is the concept that is
referred to as corresponding squares
and let us pull up the example here
and I'm going to extend the
definition so the corresponding squares
is another concept much like mowing the
lawn that is much easier to Simply
explain via an example and I really
struggled with it when I was kind of
reading it in a book uh it's it's like
so Technical and I was really confused
by it uh but the moment I really paused
to think about what it entails I
realized that it's a pretty simple
concept so I'll read the definition but
don't worry too much about taking every
word down instead try to focus on really
understanding this example I think I'll
be able to explain it in a way that you
will understand so corresponding squares
two squares will refer to them as Square
X and square y any pair of square E6 and
A6 for example our corresponding squares
if moving the king onto Square X forces
the opponent to occupy Square why that's
why they're called corresponding
crucially the defending side must
maintain that order King steps onto
Square y only after the opposing King
steps onto Square X to avoid zuzong very
very often vice versa so if there's a
corresponding pair of squares you have
to be the second person if you're
defending if you have square y then you
have to wait for your opponent to step
onto Square X and then you step onto
Square y putting your opponent in zuke's
phone if it was your move then you would
be in zuk Swang they're also called
squares of mutual zugspawn right this is
related to mind squares and as you'll
see it's very related to opposition so
in front of us is another study love
this one this is so nice because it's so
confusing if you don't get the concept
but the moment you get the concept you
can solve it almost immediately so this
is a study by a German composer friends
SackMan from 1913 I think
and White's goal is to win the game
now immediately even without calculating
anything you should notice uh the fact
that the kings are in distant opposition
and we saw a few examples of this in the
last video distance opposition I remind
you is when the kings are staring at
each other and there are three squares
or sometimes even five squares between
them so in order to solve this study the
most effective method is to draw up all
of the corresponding squares now let's
think about what what that means in the
context of this position well a much
simpler example of what a corresponding
square is comes from a position like
this let's say that it's white to move
what are the corresponding squares if
you're playing Black actually well there
whichever side you're playing right it
just depends uh a pair of corresponding
squares here for example is E4 and E6
I'm going to highlight whites squares
that square X in red and square Y in
green E4 and E6 similarly D4 and I
forgot how to there we go D4 and D6
F4 and F6 all of these are corresponding
squares so if White's King steps onto
this Square Black's King has to step
onto the corresponding Square E6 and
nowhere else that's Vicky you could have
more than one square uh that's a
correspondent but usually corresponding
squares are just one to one okay
um King D4 you can only play the king to
your uh respective corresponding Square
D6 right so it's really not that
complicated it's just the square that
you want to go to if your opponent steps
onto a certain Square now adding some
pawns adds some complexity right what is
it that black is trying to avoid well
black is trying to avoid getting
shouldered right White's very close to
shouldering Black's King and just
eliminating both of these C pawns let's
see if we can draw up the corresponding
squares black must keep the opposition
here in order to prevent white from
making progress so see if you can pause
the video and uh highlight uh mentally
highlight all of the corresponding
squares and if you can solve the
position then big could kudos to you
all right let's pour some more tea as
you guys think
okay
so to begin the process of uh annotating
this position what happens if white
plays like King D6 well our first set of
corresponding squares is obvious black
is going to drop back to B6 and this is
the only Square the black can move on to
should White's king move to D6 and
crucially if the move orders if the
order is flipped if it's black to move
here then black is in zugsvong why is
black and zugason well because black has
to move the king and start giving up all
of his pawns so our first set of
corresponding squares is D6 uh let's
again do white squares and red black
squares and green D6 B6 similarly we can
extend the path to D7 B7 d8b8 and if we
shift everything to the right we just
have the same thing except with
long-term opposition so we have E6 A6 E7
E7 A7 e88 right and we can shift things
uh to the right again you know whites
King actually can move to the f file how
does that relate to the corresponding
Square words well let's let's understand
that right if Weiss King tries to access
the f file where does Black's King want
to be
well uh if if Black's King is on the um
the a file when whites King is on the f
file then white skin can suddenly take a
sharp turn to the left and move on to
the E file now if White's King is
anywhere on the E file all of flax
corresponding squares are going to be on
the a file to uh to retain distant
opposition so the corresponding Square
for black to F6 is also B6 it's also B6
F7 B7 f8 B8 so that when White's gang
moves to the left black skin can also
move to the left maintaining that odd
number of squares between the Kings
remember if you're confused all of this
boils down to Black being able to meet
King d8 with King B8 King D7 with King
B7 and King D6 with King B6 if we're
trying to win this with white that's
what we're ultimately trying to prevent
black from doing
now the correct first move
and I will tell you the move and then
we'll derive uh the logic well actually
we can derive the logic immediately
the corresponding Square to F6 is B6 is
there a square in White's vicinity that
doesn't have a corresponding Square well
not really right F5 the corresponding
square is A5 right well that's an
interesting wait wait a second black
scene is already on A5 what's the
corresponding Square again well it's a
square that you need to move on to only
if your opponent has moved on to square
X so the XY pair is F5 A5 but black
sting is already on A5 what did I say
Well they're squares of mutual Zug swung
so black has moved on to square y before
white has moved on to square X and we
catch him in the act by playing the
first move King F5
if it was white to move here then
everything would be in order but now
black has stepped onto his corresponding
Square first and this is already zugsbon
even if it's not obvious yet so if black
plays King A6 then it's all very easy
King E6 white claims long distance
opposition the game is over King A7 and
now the winning technique is shouldering
you move up to E7
let's say King E8 and push back to D6
hopefully this technique you're already
very comfortable with King D7 and King
C8 completes the shouldering process and
I'll show the entire line a little bit
later so
King A6 is not resilient black has to
try to go King B6 now we continue to
move uh forward on the corresponding
squares we play King F6 again black
wants this position with white to move
but it's black to move if King C7 then
King E7 if King A7 then also King E7 if
uh you know black plays King A6 then
King E6 so whichever way Black Goes we
step onto the uh corresponding Square
the most resilient is King B7 and
where's the corresponding Square uh for
B7 well it's F7 so we play King F7
uh and now black is officially busted
let's say black plays King B8 now we
want to avoid playing King E8 because
this allows black to reset and shift the
king To the Left Right King A8 and now
black has rectified the order
um black has stepped onto Square y uh
after whites has stepped onto Square X
instead the correct move is King E6 I
know this is a little bit technical but
hopefully you can just see the way that
this works what was the corresponding
Square uh for E6 well it was A6 and
because of the way we've maneuvered
black can no longer access the A6 square
and therefore black gets shouldered
whatever he does for example King C8 you
might say oh black gets diagonal
opposition but no the corresponding
square is A6 here we play King D6 King
B7 and we finally reach our Target
position opposition shouldering King B6
King C8
let's say King A6 King C7 and no
stalemate white just eliminates both of
these pawns and I can also go around for
the a pawn uh if he wants to as well so
you can convince yourself if you're
still a little hazy on this by just
playing the moves out on the board if
black plays King A7 again this is
critical you don't play King D7 and
allow black to step onto the
corresponding square instead you play
King E7
and if King A8 now you double back to D6
because black cannot access B6 the king
doesn't move like a knight King D7
everything always boils down to the
situation with the white King on D7 and
the blacking on B7 and it being black to
move finally uh if black plays King C7
then King E7 and again King C8
shouldering King D6 can be seven King D7
and the game is over so that was a bit
of a whirlwind but hopefully you're able
to understand the basic idea in real
life most corresponding square examples
aren't actually quite as complicated if
you can understand the notion of mutual
zuzvong then you can go a very a very
long way but hopefully you're able to
see that you know with a keen
understanding of this concept you're
able to find a move like King F5 once
again the way you do this is you chart
all of the corresponding squares which
usually are squares of distant
opposition right and you just try to
figure right if just you can see if you
can put your opponent in a situation
where he is the first one to step onto a
mind Square this f5a5 is a pair of
corresponding squares and black is
already on A5 so we catch him in the act
with the move King F5 okay
and in the next video we will have a
practice example uh that will allow you
to test your understanding of this so
don't worry too much I know this is a
lot to swallow and now we move to our
final concept which is going to be
the notion of keeping your pawns back
now this is similar to a rule that we
discussed in the pawn race video but
it's a little bit more nuanced keep the
pawns back says that if you are
anticipating a pawn race keep your weak
pawns the ones that your opponent will
capture on route to promoting as far
away from your opponent's king as
possible to extend the time it takes for
your opponent to promote right so one of
the pawn race rules was you want to push
your prospective passer if you've
identified which Pawn uh is ultimately
going to be the racer uh you want to
it's like you know what's that term in
baseball where they're already a little
bit past the base you want to push that
pawn as far up as possible but there's
also the reverse idea which can be
harder to understand intuitively you
want to keep your pawns far back so your
opponent takes as long as possible to
take them let's illustrate that with our
final example this is a title Tuesday
game that I had against arientari it was
a painful game because I win would have
gotten me first place and with just a
couple of seconds on my clock I failed
to practice what I preached so in this
position it is white to move let's pause
the video for one last time and see if
you can decode the winning process
okay so what makes this example really
hard is that there is a super super
tempting move in this position and that
tempting move is of course C5 check
creating a past pawn and after bcbc
hopefully you're able to understand that
this is a pawn race in the making why
it's going to eliminate these two pawns
and promote the f-bond black is going to
try to promote the a pawn by eliminating
whites C and A pawns so let's calculate
black plays King C6 and well let's go
white plays King E5 well after King
takes E5 King takes F5 you'll remember
that you don't have to engage in the
pawn race King C4 loses gank takes E4
and white wins the race but
unfortunately hopefully you were able to
spot then black can actually double back
to D4 and there is nothing that white
can do here if you try to go after the H
Pawn then black will go after the F Pawn
and you know only white can lose the
game so this is why C5 fails concretely
but you could say wait a second I don't
have to go King E5 I'm going to push my
Pawn up to A4 Force Black's King back
and then go around and take all the
black spots that was my logic as well
remember I had three seconds on the
clock but what I failed to factor in is
that I am actually helping Black by
moving the a pawn up and moving the C
Pawn up and saving black crucial Tempe
instead of moving the king back which
loses a lot of time Black's only move
here is f for Kudos if you found this
move now let the pawn race begin King
takes E4 King takes E5 takes King B4 I
moved my king to the side he took F4 oh
via here here here here here and the
pods promote simultaneously to my great
disappointment now the game is not over
white can take on H5 and I think this is
winning uh theoretically but it is an
incredibly hard position to win in a
practical game and Aryan with some very
accurate defense was able to catch me in
a Perpetual check so this is clearly not
the smooth way to win the game
the mistake that is hidden in this
sequence is that the move C5 check as
natural as it is is actually wrong
because it brings the pawn up to Black
on a golden platter what you should try
to do is keep the C Pawn on C4 to make
black waste another Tempo to play King
C5 and King takes C4 rather than King
takes C5 and King B for it that's two
moves King C5 takes C4 B4 is three moves
how do we do that well once you know the
idea the execution should be pretty
straightforward you start by trading on
A5 and now we play the move A4
inevitably you have to play A4 otherwise
you're not going to inducevang right you
have to move one of the pawns closer but
you keep the C Pawn on C4
black plays King C6 If instead black
plays King E6 then you push C5 because
now black has to waste more time getting
to the pawn and white wins the race very
easily
so instead black plays King C6 and now
you have saved a crucial Tempo we had
this exact position with the pawn on C5
with a Pawn on C4 that's one tempo and
that's all that you need King takes F5
King takes C4 notice that if black tries
to follow the rule of not taking
unnecessary pawns here you can win in
several different ways but the most
elegant is just a force black to take
the pawn by playing C5 and your black
wastes uh even more moves so King takes
E4 is forced takes here F4 here F5 and
it's easy to assure yourself that indeed
white promotes first by a single Tempo
and then is able to easily blockade
black Spawn from A1 so uh the sixth rule
a continuation of upon race concept is
when you're anticipating a pawn race you
want to move your perspective passer up
as far as it'll go now it's not possible
to do that here because F2 is
immobilized by Black's pawns but the
reverse of that is you want to keep your
pawns as inaccessible to your opponent's
king as possible which often means
actually avoiding uh pushing them as
tempting as it may appear
and that ladies and gentlemen concludes
the six Advanced topics that I had
planned for this video Once Again the
video came out quite a bit longer than I
expected it to be but you know I really
hope that uh the pace wasn't too
frenetic I hope that you were able to to
benefit from this you were able to
follow the definitions uh before I close
off I'm just going to project all of
them on the screen here I'm going to
expand this View and I'm going to give
you all of these Concepts uh in one view
so that you can take them down or copy
them down as as you wish we talked about
the waiting move sacrifice generating an
additional waiting move mowing the lawn
clearing a path to a set of Pawns moving
your opponent's bonds that's a strategic
sacrifice in order to shift Pawns in a
favorable Direction often onto the
corner file uh where they are at their
worst inducing weaknesses sacking or
trading in order to transform the pawn
structure in your favor corresponding
squares confusing sounding term but
actually pretty straightforward now
let's uh any X Y Square where if your
opponent steps onto Square X you have to
step onto Square Y in that order to
avoid zog's vong and keeping the pawn
back keeping the pawns back in a pawn
race you actually often want to avoid
pushing pawns forward to make it as long
as possible for your opponent to take
all of your pawns and on that note
ladies and gentlemen I'm closing off for
today the next video is going to be a
practicum I'm going to give you 10 test
positions we're going to test all of uh
these Concepts and I think it's going to
be a really fun one hope you enjoyed
watching thank you everybody for the
amazing feedback on this series it's
made it so rewarding and so much fun uh
for me to make and uh we'll keep
carrying on there's so many more end
games to explore after Pawn end games
but on that note happy end game play
ladies and gentlemen thank you so much
again for watching over an hour I know
it's a long time and I'll see you in the
next video bye
foreign
[Music]